you're on a hike trying to figure out
how far away you are from your
destination
you pull out a map whose bar scale tells
you that one inch equals half a mile
and measuring two inches between your
current location and your destination
you conclude that you're one mile out
basic math sure but whether you realize
it or not you've just utilized a form of
the metric tensor one of the most
revolutionary revisions to our modern
geometry
but what is this idea exactly and how
has it come to play such a crucial role
in the theory of general relativity
this is dialect
and today
we're demystifying the metric tensor
[Music]
the equations of general relativity tell
us that matter and energy alter the
metric of space-time resulting in a
four-dimensional curvature that's
synonymous with gravity
the key to understanding general
relativity then is locked away somewhere
in this notion of a metric which at
every point across space and time is
characterized by ten numbers in the form
of a mathematical object called a tensor
but how can we get a deeper intuition
about this abstract idea
well let's start by taking an approach
to cartography
this is a military-grade topographical
map of fort rucker in alabama the lines
and grids covering it are a coordinate
system that allows for the precise
distinguishing and pinpointing of
different locations across the map
now the maps bar scale will tell us how
to convert from the distances on the map
to actual distances on the earth
for instance two centimeters on the map
corresponds to one kilometer on the
ground
the bar scale is thus the map's metric
or the mathematical object which
functions to convert the map's
coordinate intervals to real distances
on the ground
the value or component of this metric is
simply the ratio given by the bar scale
in this case that ratio is one to fifty
thousand
since one centimeter on the map
corresponds to fifty thousand actual
centimeters
now viewed as a whole that's all a
metric really is a bar scale it's when
we want to be more precise that the need
for a tensor arises
on our map for instance it's not
actually true that everywhere 2
centimeters will equal one kilometer
this will only be the case wherever the
topography of the terrain is relatively
flat
otherwise if it's hilly or mountainous
then all sorts of extra distances are
going to be thrown in depending on how
high the elevation and how steep the
grade of the local topography is
if we're near a cliff or a steep
mountain for instance
traversing one kilometer of horizontal
distance requires climbing a good deal
of vertical distance as well
thus in certain locations on our map two
centimeters will actually correspond to
a distance greater than one kilometer
what this means is that the value of the
metric is actually going to change in
certain locations
being nearly 1 in 50 000 in locations
that are relatively flat but being one
in more than 50 000 wherever terrain
exhibits significant curvature
[Music]
most topographical maps encode such
varying metrics via the use of contour
lines
on our fort rucker map for instance
crossing from one contour line to the
next indicates an elevation change of 10
meters
thus for a given path on the map to find
the total distance covered on the ground
you have to not only convert the
coordinate distance of the path into
real world horizontal distance but you
also have to count the number of contour
lines crossed by the path to determine
that path's change in vertical distance
you can then estimate the path's total
distance via a simple pythagorean
relation
the ratio of the original coordinate
distance to this final distance is what
yields the true value of the metric over
the path traveled
of course to make this metric as
accurate as possible you have to keep
making the path size smaller and smaller
so that variances in local topography
are accounted for
essentially you can cut the map into
very small pieces and then assign a
metric value to each piece
this is like giving each little tiny
patch on the map its own different bar
scale
[Music]
then as we travel across different
patches on the map
we can sum over those bar scales to
determine how the actual distance on the
ground changes with respect to any
specified change in coordinates
the usefulness of this is of course that
one can determine one's real-world
distance traveled simply by knowing the
coordinate path traveled on the map
so now we have a better understanding of
what the metric does
assigns a bar scale to each piece of the
map
but where do all these extra numbers of
the tensor come from
well maybe you noticed that our fort
rucker map required two components at
each point to define its metric
one for the horizontal distance
conversion and one for the vertical
distance conversion
so
for a two-dimensional surface or
manifold
it might seem like you need two numbers
to characterize your metric
but a map like fort rucker actually
takes advantage of certain symmetries in
order to reduce the number of components
needed to describe its metric
consider making a map of the earth
if like our fort rocker map you approach
it from a sort of top down projection
you'll end up with a map that looks like
this
notice that the lines of latitude here
play the same role as the contour lines
did in our fort rucker map
the closer they are together the steeper
the topography is relative to our
projection
thus the value of our metric grows
smaller and smaller the closer we get
towards the equator
because more and more real-world
distance is traversed by the same amount
of coordinate distance
consequently the shape of landmasses
near the equator gets squashed and
distorted
now because this map has a unique radial
symmetry
you'd actually only need to specify one
number or parameter to characterize the
metric at any point
but if we want a map of the entire earth
this obviously won't suffice
instead we would need a projection more
like this
this robinson projection is different
from the other maps we've been looking
at so far
why
because not only does it distort
distances making land masses like
greenland or antarctica which are
further away from the equator appear
larger than they actually are but it
also distorts angles
notice for instance that along this line
of latitude near the north pole the
lines of longitude all intersect it at
different angles
yet if you looked at the same lines on a
globe you would see that they all
intersect at right angles or 90 degrees
thus at each of these points on the map
if you wanted to give the value of the
real angle between the coordinate lines
you would need a sort of angle metric to
convey the amount of coordinate skew
this gives us an idea of what our third
and final component of the metric must
do
somehow it must indicate to us how our
angles change across different points of
the map
but to be precise and really figure out
how each of these metric components
relates to the other we need to look at
the process that actually goes into
making these types of maps
that is let's ask
how do we take a curved surface like
that of a globe and make it into a flat
surface like that of a map
well the method is pretty simple and it
works like this
we take the sphere or curve surface that
we are trying to depict and start by
dividing it into many small pieces that
are most nearly flat
then we surgically cut all those pieces
apart and put them back together on a
flat surface like pieces of a puzzle
at this point however the puzzle pieces
won't fit together all that well and
there will be many gaps and holes
to get rid of those gaps we perform a
simple operation upon each of the pieces
we stretch and or skew the piece until
it fits into place
then we can assemble our map into a
contiguous hole
now the operations of stretching and
skewing are pretty easy to describe
mathematically
stretching merely assigns a new scale to
your coordinate intervals
skewing meanwhile turns coordinate
squares into coordinate parallelograms
and consequently right triangles into
obtuse or acute triangles
so your distance element goes from being
the hypotenuse of a right triangle to
being one of the sides in an obtuse or
an acute triangle
and if you remember the extension of the
pythagorean theorem from basic geometry
you'll know that you need exactly three
numbers to calculate the length of the
side of a non-right triangle
you need the length of the first side
the length of the second side
and the cosine of the angle between them
and voila
this is where your three values of the
metric come
from so for each tiny region of our map
we need one number or bar scale to tell
us how much our x-axis has been
stretched or shrunk
one number or bar scale to tell us how
much our y-axis has been stretched or
shrunk and one number to tell us how
much the angle between the axes has been
skewed
[Music]
the tinier we make these regions the
more accurate our metric will become and
the better we can describe our curved
surface
the list of these three numbers put
together is called the metric tensor and
it is easily generalized to higher
dimensions
by adding one more bar scale for each
new dimension
plus one new cosine angle value for
every pairing of dimensions that can be
skewed
geometrically we can interpret the
number of metric components as being the
number of sides and angles you'd need to
specify in order to determine the length
of the diagonal of an nth dimensional
parallelogram
so in two dimensions you'll need three
numbers at each point on your map to
characterize the metric
while in three dimensions you'll need
six numbers
and for four dimensions like that of
general relativity space time you'll
need four lengths and six angles
or ten numbers total to fully
characterize the metric at any point
together these numbers give us that
final desired value
the value of the bar scale we need for
each patch of our map
[Music]
and as we stated at the beginning of our
video that's all the metric tensor
really is
just a fancy bar scale
an important note to make here is that
the framework of the metric tensor
treats coordinate systems and the
surfaces or manifolds that they describe
as fundamentally distinct entities
[Music]
and although so far we've been dealing
with metrics that go between different
coordinate systems on different
manifolds you can also have metrics
which describe different coordinate
systems on the same manifold
an example of this would be going
between cartesian and polar coordinates
on a flat manifold
because your initially cartesian surface
once cut into many small pieces and then
stretched skewed and rearranged
according to a polar coordinate ordering
still retains its original flatness
the separation between coordinate
systems and manifolds can be an
intuitively difficult pill to swallow
but it's a crucial idea which ultimately
leads to the more sophisticated concept
of curvature
for the moment however the main takeaway
here is that the metric tensor becomes
involved whenever you're using some type
of map
meaning the representation of one
surface by that of another
the trick to understanding general
relativity then is to realize that not
all maps are two-dimensional pieces of
paper you can hold in your hand
[Music]
so if you're planning on taking a hike
through say a black hole
you're going to need something of a
four-dimensional map
but more on that in future videos
this has been dialect thanks for
watching
[Music]